♫♫
-Oh, our first team tonight
from the hit show "Riverdale."
It´s "Riverdale" party!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And from Nashville, Tennessee,
it´s the Cyrus party.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
All right. Jimmy and Lili,
you are up first.
Come on over.
Come on down.
[ Cheers ]
Here´s how the game works.
I will read you the start of
an Internet search question,
and then you will fill
in the blank.
We have four of...
-Use your TV voice.
-...the most popular answers
on the board,
and you´ll both type
as fast as you can.
We´ll see if any of them match
the top four answers.
-All right.
-Here´s our first search.
Here´s our first search.
Round one, Jimmy and Lili --
Should I pierce my "blank"?
[ Laughter ]
Is everybody locked in?
-Did I lock it in?
-Lock it in.
-Yeah.
-It´s a family show.
All right, Jimmy,
what did you write?
This is a Website I tried
to start and it didn´t take off.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Tumblr type of thing.
This is called Nipplr.
And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-Nipplr?
-Well, I meant to type nipple,
but I typed "nipplr."
-Nipplr.
[ Laughter ]
-It´s a weather app.
-See it´s the weather app
if it´s nippy out.
-See if it´s nippy out.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Sure, sure, sure.
-It´s a weather app.
-You got to keep abreast
of the weather.
-All right, Lili --
-Thank you.
-What did you type?
-I mean, I am strategic.
So, you know, I did with
what I thought would be
the right answer.
[ Laughter ]
So I --
-Oh, my God.
The sarcasm is insane.
Wow.
-I did nose.
-Nose.
Nose and nipplr, let´s see them.
Whoa!
Got nipples and nose!
You got it!
♫♫
All righty.
-You got it.
-See?
-Rigged.
-Nipplr, man.
-Nipplr.
-Free the nipplr.
Free the nipplr.
Miley, how are you, my love?
-I´m great, how are you?
Once again, most popular word
to complete the search --
Should I pierce my "blank"?
-You´re asking me?
-Yes.
-Remember --
-This is bad.
This is a family show.
-All right, so my first one
is out the window.
-Right.
-What other things?
-So is your second and third.
-All right, I have to go to,
like, my fifth answer.
-Yes.
-But do I say it out loud?
-[ Laughing ] Yes.
-Okay, it´s --
-Yeah, say it to yourself.
-I´ll say tongue.
-Tongue.
Should I pierce my tongue?
-That´s good.
-Let´s see tongue.
[ Buzzer ]
-Boom!
-That´s a fail.
-I bet my real one
would have been good.
-I bet it would have been.
-Yeah.
You can whisper it
to me later.
Noah, how are you?
-Good, how are you?
-What is the answer?
Should I pierce my what?
-Should I pierce my ears?
-Ears!
-Yes, of course!
-Let´s see ears.
Ears.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Number two answer.
Tish, darling.
-Keep it classy, Mom.
-Up there at number four.
-I´m going to keep it classy.
-Keep it classy.
What you got?
-My lip?
-Should I pierce my lip?
Let´s see lip.
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Shouting indistinctly ]
-That is a fail.
Over to "Riverdale" to steal.
K.J.?
You guys got an answer?
-There´s only so many things
you can pierce.
-That´s true.
-On the human body.
-Well, you maybe.
[ Laughter ]
-Zing!
You guys can confer,
confabulate.
-Can we call family members?
[ Talking over each other ]
-What is it?
-Belly button.
Let´s see belly button.
If they get belly button --
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers ]
"Riverdale" won!
Wow.
-What are we talking about?
That was a barn-burner!
Time for round two.
K.J., Miley, you´re up.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Complete this search question --
Can you milk a "blank"?
Again, family show.
Type it in,
whatever you think it is.
Tell me when
you are locked in.
-Okay.
-Locked and loaded.
-I´m locked and loaded.
-Press the red button.
-All right.
Press the red button.
Miley, what did you write?
-Kitten.
[ Laughter ]
-And, K.J., what did you write?
-Goat.
Kitten and goat.
Let´s see it!
[ Ding ]
Cat, oh!
Team Cyrus the Nashville team
over here!
K.J., take a seat!
-Everyone knows
you can milk a goat.
Come on, man. Can you milk it --
That´s the question.
-It´s a little convenient
that the house keeps winning.
-No. Come on.
-We have no idea.
-I´m just kind of saying.
-Can you milk a cat?
I mean, who would know --
that´s great.
[ Talking over each other ]
-All right, Noah, to you.
-I don´t know!
-Just think of one.
Think of one.
-A dog?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no no.
-I bet it´s on there.
I bet it´s on there.
-I bet it is.
-Let´s see dog.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good job.
-What world do we live in?
Yikes. What is going on?
-We are from the South.
This isn´t fair.
-This is weird.
-We´re all Southern.
-All right.
-We milk everything there.
-Right. You milk everything
in the South.
-Can you milk a --
-I mean,
I´m just gonna go with cow.
-Yes, thank you.
-Cow.
Let´s see cow.
-Thank you.
[ Buzzer ]
-What?
-These are people...
-...asking the Internet.
-I know.
-They are asking the Internet,
can you milk this thing?
What is a thing that people
might think you can milk?
-Okay.
-People.
-Ew.
-No, it´s my turn.
-Okay, sorry.
-It´s Brandi´s turn.
-I´m gonna go with llama.
-Llama.
-Llama!
-That´s interesting.
-Okay.
-Now, if you don´t get this one,
it´s "Riverdale´s" to steal.
-Can you --
let´s see llama!
[ Buzzer ]
Ooh!
That´s the second fail.
"Riverdale."
-Cole, what are you thinking?
-What do you guys got?
-It´s our turn now.
-Yeah.
-It´s team "Riverdale."
-What are we thinking?
What are we thinking?
-Or, or or --
-Huddle, huddle.
-What are we thinking?
[ Talking over each other ]
-All right. You have it?
Your answer?
-You guys seem very confident.
-Take it away.
-We are.
-Cole, go for it.
-Pig.
-Pig! Let´s see pig!
-Not bad.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Shouting ]
-No pig! Let´s see
what the answers were.
[ Ding ]
Horse!
-I told you.
[ Ding ]
-And man.
[ Cheers ]
-Hey, now -- stop it.
Stop it. Stop it!
-Jiminy Christmas.
Let´s get to the final round
and get this over.
-All right.
The final round, Noah and Cole,
you are up.
-Noah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You´re going down.
-Okay, this is the final round.
This is for the game.
-Complete
this Internet search.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-He didn´t ask you yet.
-No, not yet.
-And then delete your history.
-Why are people
afraid of "blank"?
Tell me when you´re locked in.
-Wait, what?
-I did it.
-Did you do it?
-Yeah?
-All right, what did you write,
Noah?
-I wrote dogs.
-Why are people
afraid of dogs?
-Cole, what did you write?
-I wrote me.
-Why are people
afraid of me?
-People afraid of you?
No one is afraid of you.
-All right, watch.
-Oh, really?
-Let´s see. Let´s see.
Me and dogs.
[ Buzzer ]
-No one is afraid
of either one.
-Jimmy.
-Well, that´s comforting to me
at least.
-Why are people afraid
of the dark?
-Ooh, the dark.
-That´s mine.
-Let´s see dark.
-Are you speaking
from experience?
[ Ding ]
-The dark!
All right, team Cyrus
is going over there.
-Here we go.
Here we go.
-Ready to go back over there?
[ Applause ]
-Another one?
-Miley, it´s up to you.
Why are people afraid of...
-Clowns?
-Ooh.
-Yes, of course.
-That´s a good one.
-"It"!
-Very topical.
Very topical.
Let´s see clowns.
[ Ding ]
-That´s number one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, Noah, round two?
-Again?
-Again.
-Oh. Okay.
-Things you are afraid of.
What are people afraid of?
-Oh, heights.
-Oh, that´s a good one.
-Heights.
Let´s see heights!
[ Buzzer ]
-First fail.
Tish.
-Oh, I know. I know.
I know.
-One more fail.
What are people afraid of?
-Ghosts.
-Yes!
-That was a good one.
-Let´s see ghosts.
[ Buzzer ]
-Fail.
-Oh!
Over to "Riverdale" to steal.
They can win this entire game.
-If they don´t win this,
we win the whole thing.
-No, if they win this,
they win the whole thing.
-That´s right.
But if they lose this, we win.
-Then you win the whole thing.
-That´s what I´m talking about.
-They get one guess.
You guys get one guess
to win this entire game.
-I know.
-Insects, insects.
-I know, I know.
-This is it,
for the win or the lose.
-Spiders.
-That´s a very good answer.
Spiders, let´s see spiders.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a winner.
-My thanks to the Cyrus family,
my team.
The cast of "Riverdale."